when we make new discoveries we need to
be able to share them with others and
the first thing we have to do is make
sure everyone is on the same page
we do this by using units and frames of
reference which are also called
reference frames
we talk about units in another video so
let's look at what a frame of reference
is
let's say this blue box thing is a car
and it's going 45 miles per hour
someone standing on the side of the road
would see it pass at 45 miles per hour
now if this yellow truck
is going 40 miles per hour
someone sitting in the yellow truck
would observe the blue car traveling at
5 miles per hour
how could the person on the side of the
road see the blue car traveling at 45
miles per hour and a person in the
yellow truck see the blue car moving at
five miles per hour
this is because both observers are using
different frames of reference
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that starting with the speed of the blue
car
the person on the side of the road is
using their frame of reference of being
at rest so relative to them the blue car
is moving at 45 miles per hour
to the person in this yellow truck which
remember is already going 40 miles per
hour
the blue car
is going 5 miles per hour
now let's do the exact same thing for
the speed of the yellow truck
so what is the speed of the yellow truck
for the observer on the side of the road
it's 40 miles per hour
and what do you think the speed of the
truck is for the person using their blue
car as the reference frame
well the blue car is moving at 45 miles
per hour and the truck is only moving at
40 miles per hour
so the speed of the yellow truck is
actually five miles per hour slower than
this reference frame because the blue
car
is already moving at 45 miles per hour
now you might be thinking but wait the
person on the side of the road isn't
really at rest
they're on the earth and the earth is
moving
you're completely correct
the person is at rest with respect to
the earth
and the earth is the most common frame
of reference that we use to an observer
in space who is not rotating with the
earth
the blue car is going 45 miles per hour
plus the speed of earth's rotation
and this is why frame of reference is so
important we just talked about one blue
car having three different velocities
depending what the frame of reference is
how would we communicate this to avoid
confusion
well we state the reference frame we're
using
the blue car is moving at five miles per
hour with respect to which i'll write as
wrt
the yellow truck
this tells us that the yellow truck is
our frame of reference
or we could say that the yellow truck
is moving at 40 miles per hour and the
blue car at 45 miles per hour with
respect to the earth
that way everyone is on the same page a
page which to be clear isn't a book that
relative to me is at rest